we are less than two weeks away from
thanksgiving but it seems more and more
las vegas are decorating for christmas
already
they're trying to make a difficult year
a little bit brighter 8 news now
reporter madison kimbrough joins us live
in the northwest valley
with more on this good evening madison
yes the holidays are near and we are in
some major
need of some major cheer this year and
people are doing so
by putting out their decorations early
as you can see behind me now take a look
as we shot some video earlier where you
could see several people this year
putting christmas decorations up
even before thanksgiving trying to get
themselves and others into a cheerful
spirit
with the pandemic completely taking over
2020
many families feel this is a good way to
end the year doing so on a brighter note
literally we spoke to some people that
have their homes decorated already take
a listen
honestly just like changes everyone's
mood makes everyone just a little bit
more happier this year
i absolutely love seeing the kids come
by and just like check out the
decorations and stuff it does put a
smile on their face especially with like
adults
you know it definitely does and take a
look behind me where you can really see
the extent
of this man's decorations you can see he
has a snowman he has merry christmas a
penguin
and then you can also see reindeer and
santa sleigh
so he says that he started decorating
right after
halloween can you even imagine what his
decorations would have looked like at
halloween time
wow all right well sending it back to
you